we're joined now by Judge Andrew
Napolitano and happy to be a judge
thanks for joining us so you spent the
last well the 20 years I've known you
talking about civil liberties and how
central they are to the American
experiment they're enshrined in our
documents of course I haven't heard any
talk about them recently are they still
relevant you know one of our colleagues
sent me a cartoon of the framers signing
the Constitution and in this cartoon
Washington turns to Madison and says let
me get this straight
none of this counts of people get sick
right you know sort of a humorous way of
mocking what's happening today your
analysis of Governor Whitmer could apply
to nearly all the remaining 49 governors
who assume that they have the power to
crush individual liberties violate the
Constitution and write laws well they
don't laws in this country are written
by legislative branches after public
hearings and debates of this a
transparency so we would know why she
doesn't want you to buy garden hoses
there have to be a rational basis
articulated for it but when the
executive branch takes upon itself the
role of not just enforcing the law but
of making up new ones and when in the
process it crushes basic fundamental
liberties like the right to travel and
the right to worship never mind on
Easter Sunday but on any time you want
to worship we are witnessing the slow
death the death and slow motion of civil
liberties because these governors these
petty tyrants will use this power again
and again until some courageous federal
court or an outraged public stops them
I'm so thankful that you pointed out
it's it's not just governor Whitmer I
mean it's governor Hogan in Maryland
it's governor Klan robes in Virginia
it's virtually all of them very quickly
do you think there's a mechanism for
pulling them back a little bit now
hopefully it'll be outraged stirred up
by the type of reporting the you and
some of our colleagues have
begun to be doing and even some of our
colleagues on the Left have been doing
some of this reporting but basic human
Liberty our liberties are guaranteed in
the Constitution they can't even be
taken away by the vote of a legislature
much less the command of a governor or
or a or a mayor these executive orders
look like orders and sound like orders
there are just guidelines they don't
have the force of law there cannot be a
criminal sanction for the failure to
comply with them because they are at
their at their root just the whim of
those in power intended to enhance their
power they're not valid expressions of
constitutional doctrine thank you for
reminding us for that Judge Napolitano
great to see you tonight thank you for
having me